se extiende sobre más de 17 estados de
brasil desde el norte del país pasando
por río de janeiro sao paulo hasta las
célebres cataratas de iguazú en el
extremo sur
diezmada por la agricultura y la
urbanización intensiva la mata atlántica
ha perdido casi el 90% de su superficie
original
miren el yerno con muchísimo normalmente
el agua llega hasta aquí hoy en día lo
poco que queda del bosque está amenazado
por una sequía histórica
aquí es cuando el reservorio está lleno
cada mes malú ribeiro y su equipo vienen
a controlar el nivel y la calidad del
agua del único reservorio en esta región
a las afueras de sao paulo si alrededor
no estuviera este bosque que sembramos
el reservorio de agua probablemente
tendría un nivel mucho más bajo y mucho
más crítico y con una concentración de
contaminantes muy superior así que este
bosque la mata atlántica pues un papel
esencial es como una esponja que retiene
el agua y ayuda a regular el clima
está zona vegetal es muy seca y está
rodeada de campos carreteras y sectores
urbanos con mucho tráfico así que el
riesgo de incendio es muy alto
sin embargo el código forestal obliga a
los propietarios de los terrenos a
resembrar para contener estos estanques
de agua pero la ley no es respetada
muchos estados del país alentados por el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro quieren bajar
de categoría a la mata atlántica para
que pierda su condición de territorio
protegidas no si nuestras grandes
ciudades como sao paulo o las
principales capitales regionales del
país se quedan sin agua entrarán en un
declive económico es vital que brasil
deja de ir a contracorriente reconozca
la importancia de proteger este bosque
de la mata atlántica
desde 2007 la asociación ss mata
atlántica da ejemplo en esta antigua
granja agrícola completamente
reforestada sus miembros luchan por
impedir la desaparición del bosque
actualmente tenemos una capacidad de
producción de 700 mil brotes al año
desde que comenzamos nuestro trabajo
hemos hecho crecer más de 110 especies
diferentes todas nativas de la mata
atlántica
su misión darles semillas y plantas a
los propietarios de los terrenos y a los
habitantes algunos han entendido bien su
mensaje
en el corazón de la megalópolis de sao
paulo el parqué de ético a tira se
extiende sobre 7 kilómetros
33 mil árboles endémicos de brazil
sembrados aquí desde 2003 es la
increíble apuesta de un solo hombre
elliot a silbar
sin estos árboles que ven acá sembrados
en el terraplén la tierra se había
venido abajo a la reflexión y el paso de
los autos por encima y claro lo que
retiene todo eso lo que mantiene esta
barrera son las raíces de los armas
antes era un terreno baldío había nada
solo desechos estaba abandonado
sin ninguna suspensión este apasionado
compró la mayoría de las plantas con sus
fondos personales aunque actualmente el
parque es mantenido por la alcaldía
junto con un amigo voluntario el yo
sigue sembrando dos árboles nuevos todos
los días cada árbol joven cuesta menos
de un dólar el año pasado gaste casi
siete mil dólares
este es un ip blatter un árbol que nació
el yo se ha ganado un sobrenombre el
salvador de la mata y una reputación yo
creía que era imposible nada
nada es imposible
es genial yo creía que usted era una
leyenda
pero usted está aquí está vivo y está
vamos
a preferiría que mis queridos árboles
sean los famosos y celebrados este árbol
por ejemplo se llama canela burham puede
albergar hasta 51 especies de pájaros
la mata atlántica es un refugio esencial
para la fauna brasileña
la protección de este bosque permite que
muchas especies amenazadas puedan
sobrevivir
en esta reserva protegida de la región
de río gracias a las cámaras los
científicos estudian la presencia de
pumas de los elotes pequeño felino de
américa del sur o incluso
ah
de este curioso animal reintroducido hoy
después de un viaje de 1500 kilómetros
desde el norte del país resta pires
entran a la reserva bajo la supervisión
del biólogo marón calles
el tapir ocupa un lugar fundamental en
este ecosistema es llamado el jardinero
del bosque porque al desplazarse
dispersa las semillas facilitando así la
restauración de la selva y la
biodiversidad local
casado por su carne y arrinconado por la
deforestación galopante de la mata
atlántica este herbívoro prehistórico
fue diezmado por el ser humano en el
siglo 19
es maravilloso se está adaptando a su
nuevo entorno el tapir es un animal muy
vinculado con el agua siempre busca
estar cerca del agua para refrescarse o
para esconderse de un eventual
depredador es muy emocionante para mí
ver el resultado de este proyecto
para considerar que la especie ha sido
reintroducida al menos 50 tapires
deberán estar reunidos aquí un trabajo
de largo aliento esperando por fin poder
alcanzar un nuevo equilibrio un nuevo
futuro para la mata atlántica